joe rogan
joe rogan is giving great news to the
republicans we've seen a lot of good
signs in recent months that they're
going to do well in the midterm
elections the generic congressional
ballot the misery index the simple fact
that it's the first midterm of a new
president all of that points to good
news for the party out of power
yesterday the gop received a better omen
than all of those others combined
joe rogan told his audience that he
wants them to vote republican
no one who is alive today had ever
experienced a true pandemic
and i'm hoping that now that this is
over people are going to
you know recognize that some serious
errors were made and not repeat those
that's the best you can get out of it so
what do you tell those people vote
republican
[Laughter]
that's what a lot of them are going to
do anyway yeah yeah oh yeah i mean more
than a million people transferred over
to the republican party
uh i think in 2021 alone find out what
that number is
but you know you look at guys like ron
desantis who kept florida open and had
some pretty reasonable policies in terms
of like what what to do about covid and
you know he mapped it out on television
he was
you know widely criticized for this
where he was saying like we need to
protect our elders we need to you know
make sure that medical care is available
for those people and everyone else you
should be able to do whatever you want
to do protect your freedom
those 55 seconds from joe rogan are more
important than any
poli-sci nerd analysis more important
than 10 000 pages of data from every
four-eyed pollster in america because
joe rogan is the generic voter
joe rogan speaks two and four
more people than just about anyone else
in america as goes joe rogan
so goes
the country in many ways after 18 months
of record high inflation of foreign
policy disaster of mass illegal
migration of a collapse in law and order
and a creeping sense that our
institutions of government are being
rigged and wielded by democrats for
their own personal gain whether it's the
fbi pressuring facebook to censor the
hunter biden laptop story whether it's
the doj busting through donald trump's
store at mar-a-lago the american people
right now are signaling in every way
they can that they intend to vote the
bums
out
and yet
only one thing is certain
the more that the people express support
for republicans in november
the more the establishment will smear
them all as a threat to democracy
there's a lot of oppression in the
country not just the oppression of the
conservatives at the hands of the libs
who changed the election rules no no
i'm talking about the oppression
of
celebrities and music stars at the video
music awards i'm talking about the
oppression of lizzo who as she's
accepting her award
she reminds everyone they need to go out
and vote to stop all the oppression
i don't know
what uh music video for good means but i
do know what your vote means
and that's a
lot
your vote means everything
to me
it means everything to making a change
in this country
[Music]
so remember when you're voting for your
favorite artist vote to change some of
these laws that are oppressing us
now of course lizzo is probably the
single least oppressed person on earth
she is maybe she's oppressed by our
decadent culture
but she's certainly not oppressed by
any of the things that ordinarily would
would be considered oppressive she has
as many political rights as she want she
has the abundance of material goods she
she can do whatever she pleases
that's why lizzo is not being detailed
here she's not she's not saying what
laws we should vote against she's not
even saying what candidates to vote
against she's not saying what is
oppressing her
she's just saying yeah it's it's
oppressive you got to go vote
it's just the kind of
most ridiculous conclusion of puff
daddy's
campaign from 2004 vote or die remember
he had that campaign he said vote or die
because they were trying to kick george
bush out of office
you say uh i don't think those are the
only two options
i don't think a consequence of not
voting will be that we all die i doubt
that
it's just so vague it's just these
people being used as parrots for the
entrenched powers for the liberal
establishment a woman wearing a very
fancy expensive dress holding a gold
statue saying i'm so oppressed be sure
to go out and vote against the bad guys
for the good guys because of the
oppression and it's not
really persuasive anymore if it ever was
persuasive which i don't think it was
don't forget puff daddy's vote or die
thing did not work
but if it ever was persuasive i just
think advances in technology so that now
we're not just beholden to the main news
networks we actually do research
ourselves that really dealt a tough blow
to the establishment uh changes in power
the fact the fact now that these libs
who used to be
on the fringes of power who used to be
able to somewhat credibly claim that
they were fighting the man now that they
just dominate the entire establishment
the fact that
whenever you see the resistance and blm
and the pride flag it's always being
pushed by gazillion dollar corporations
and institutions of the government that
i think has changed it and the fact that
these guys have lost the common sense
the fact that the libs push transing the
kids and killing all the babies and
opening up all of our borders and
destroying our currency and locking us
all down over the woofloo the the and
the fact that that they won't even close
down gay bath houses to stop monkey pox
i mean just the on issue after issue
after issue the libs have so lost the
common sense
that they lose the generic voter okay
and they and they lose joe rogan and
they lose the people who represent the
kind of
open-minded middle in american politics
and and no speeches from lizzo are going
to change that i'm so glad you like that
clip now
you got to ring that bell subscribe i
know we hit a million subscribers i want
to hit one quintillion i know it's
ambitious we can do it ring the bell
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]